[Applause]
[Music]
if you look at a map of
spain you will see that there is a
little dot right on the border with
france
that dot is not a typo it's actually a
country
and it is called andorra it has 70 000
inhabitants and
for some time now it has been trending
in the spanish media because of news
stories like this one
about spain's biggest youtuber
el rubios announces that he is moving to
andorra and reopens the debate on the
payment of taxes by influencers
lp that is right believe it or not
andorra has become the trendy
destination for lots of youtubers
mainly spanish ones but we're not only
talking about youtubers from artists to
professional poker players and dora
seems to be on the verge of becoming a
sort of
silicon valley of online entertainment
and what is it about this country that
attracts
so many people well the answer is simple
low taxes
andorra has one of the lowest tax rates
in the world
[Music]
in spain for example this has generated
a tremendous ideological debate
is it right or wrong to move to another
country to pay
less taxes and at this point we are not
going to enter into that debate because
there is an even more
interesting question a question that
almost nobody has asked in any of the
media outlets and the question is this
can you name any media companies in
andorra
probably not right and in this video
we're going to explain why but first we
must digress
just a little bit in the media andorra
is often described as a tax haven and
that is not true andorra may have low
taxes but it is not part of the list of
tax havens
at least not at the moment keep this in
mind because it is going to be a very
important point throughout this video
what we can say
is that andorra is one of those european
microstates yes that's the thing
microstates but it's one of those
european microstates with very
very low taxes however look at this
graph
unlike other microstates such as
liechtenstein or monaco andorra is not
particularly rich in 2018 had a per
capita income of 42
000 in other words it was more or less
at the level of france
put it another way for a country that
attracts so many millionaires
and dora is far from being an ultra rich
nation and the question is
why why are there no big companies in
andorra despite the low taxes
and more importantly could andorra
really become
a hollywood for youtubers just imagine
such an awful place
in other words if you're a youtuber and
you're thinking about moving to this
country
is it a good or a bad idea today we're
going to answer
all of these questions but first let's
look at some history
[Music]
the country that wanted to copy
liechtenstein it is impossible to talk
about andorra without comparing it with
liechtenstein the guys watching know
what i'm talking about they look like
twins
both are microstates located between
large mountains and both of them have
low taxes
liechtenstein has about 30 000
inhabitants and dora
has 70 thousand one point and aura
lechenstein is in the alps and andorra
is in the pyrenees
both countries are principalities have
maintained some degree of sovereignty
for centuries and remained neutral
during world war ii
specifically andorra allowed many jews
to escape from occupied france to spain
during the franco dictatorship in spain
andorra allowed the transit of scores of
republican exiles and refugees at that
time the french president general de
gaulle
even sent french troops to protect
andorra from a possible spanish invasion
however the andorra we know today was
founded in 1982 that is when they
approved the constitution they have now
and they cut all their ties of
dependence that they had
with france and now think about it for
just one moment what do you do when you
are a small country isolated between
mountains and without any big industries
how can such a country prosper
well andorra decided to imitate the
liechtenstein model that's how they
became a tax haven
low taxes low or non-existent vat and
above all
banking secrecy in other words andorran
banks were not obliged to share
information about their clients with
other states
with this move andorra was hoping to
become a financial center the
switzerland or the liechtenstein of the
pyrenees the problem is
that they never succeeded for decades
andorra was a place to ski
buy cheap boom boxes after all it was
the 80s and launder catch
what's more as it was considered a tax
haven by almost all european countries
there were lots
and i mean lots of restrictions on doing
business with them the case of
liechtenstein is very different while
andorra's only major industry is tourism
liechtenstein has developed its own
industry and its own companies however
all of this changed in 2016.
[Music]
the end of banking secrecy in andorra
triggers regularizations
elven guardian again just like electric
stein had done a decade before
andorra put an end to banking secrecy
that explains why since 2018
andorra disappeared from the list of tax
havens in the european union and i know
what many of you will be thinking that
must have been
the end of andorran banking right quite
a crisis for such a small country right
well actually it was nothing of the sort
as of 2018 andorra appeared on the list
of possible destinations for many large
fortunes above all
those who have online businesses why
well we're going to take a look at that
right now
the hollywood of youtubers imagine that
you have a small business
on the internet you can work anywhere in
the world where would you live
in a country like spain where you could
find yourself paying more than 45
income tax or in andorra where you only
pay 10 percent
remember this microstate is just 200
kilometers that's under 124 miles from
barcelona there's even a barcelona
andorra helicopter route although the
official language is catalan you can get
by in spanish without any problem and
you're probably thinking is it really
that easy to move to andorra and the
answer is
yeah it sort of is basically all you
need to do is pay fifteen thousand euros
that's roughly eighteen thousand dollars
to the andorran tax authorities and own
at least
twenty one percent of a local business
if you cannot find a business you can
create one yourself the share capital is
three thousand euros the same as in
spain the difference is in the taxes in
spain one of andorra's two neighboring
countries the maximum corporate tax rate
is 25
while in andorra it is 10
[Music]
so what do a lot of people do they set
up a company and give themselves a
salary of 40 000 euros a year around
forty eight thousand us dollars the
first twenty four thousand are tax free
and the other sixteen thousand euros are
taxed at five percent
the rest of the money is collected in
the form of dividends from the company
which are also tax-free they only pay
ten percent corporate income tax as you
can see
this looks like a smart move so if
you'll excuse me i'm going to go and get
myself over to andorra
but before i go i should probably ask
myself how it is possible
for a state to finance itself with such
low taxes in theory it should be
possible 58
of taxpayers are foreigners and many of
whom have high incomes and i say
it should be possible because the
reality is that andorra has
significant holes in its accounts but
we'll talk about that
later so is it really that easy can the
neighboring countries really not do
anything to persecute the rich who
migrate to andorra the truth is
no basically if you reside in andorra
for more than 183 days of the year and
your main center of economic interest is
outside spain or france the state can't
do anything against you but
for that to work of course you have to
be willing to live in andorra and have
this tiny country be your main center of
economic interest
and now you'll see but wait a minute if
a youtuber has a channel in spanish his
or her income will come from spain right
well the answer
is no advertisements and sponsorships
could come from many different countries
the same goes for the audience it could
be from spain latin america
the middle east the united states or
literally anywhere on the planet that
has spanish speakers or so that spanish
speakers move to in other words there is
no reason why a spanish youtuber should
have to pay taxes in
spain if he or she does not live there
full-time as it stands under the current
law there is only one way to prosecute
someone who is taxed in andorra prove
that he or she
does not live or work there for example
if an andorran youtuber set up a company
in spain and all his or her income came
from there then they could have a
problem
in fact there are examples of artists
who pretended to live in andorra and in
the end have been nabbed by the spanish
treasury
check this out
[Music]
shakira will face a criminal case for
defrauding the tax authorities of 14.5
million
el pai not shakira turns out she
couldn't hide that small and humble
fortune in the mountains of andorra but
why
why would anyone want to set up a
company outside of andorra isn't andorra
supposed to be the ideal place to do
business
and this this is where the catch that
nobody ever tells us about this country
comes in
you see when we started researching this
video we thought that andorra looked set
to become a youtuber hollywood however
as we search through the information
one thing struck us and dora may already
have the highest concentration of famous
youtubers per capita
on planet earth but strangely it has no
large recording studios no multi-channel
networks nor any kind of auxiliary
companies and you're probably thinking
now
so why is that what's going on here well
we're gonna look at that
right now
[Music]
why andorra is not liechtenstein so
one thing is certain andorra knows how
to attract large fortunes
but back to the first question of this
video do you know any andorran companies
for example
ireland is also a country famous for its
low taxes that explains
in part why the big tech companies chose
this country to set up their european
headquarters
google facebook and apple all have huge
offices
in ireland but we are not only talking
about foreign companies
ryanair and primark are international
companies that were started
in ireland and something similar happens
with liechtenstein you can drive through
lichenstein from north to south in 15
minutes and throughout the entire trip
you will see factories and offices just
one after the other factory office
factory office
and i know what many of you are thinking
lichtenstein i don't know any companies
from liechtenstein before i started
watching this video i didn't know there
was a lichtenstein well
you actually probably do know companies
from there have you heard of one called
hilti they are the world leader in tools
and construction machinery in fact
many of you probably have a healthy
drill in your toolbox and
no matter where you live if you go to
any construction site you will find
structures designed by that company
[Music]
they have a global presence however the
most important factoring and research
and development center is in skan which
is a small village of six thousand
inhabitants located in the principality
of liechtenstein but that's not all
the next time you go to a dentist and i
know what some of you are thinking
you're thinking grant look at your teeth
you've never been to a dentist you are
british and you may be right but the
next time
you go take a look at the machines
around you i'm sure many of them will
have ivoclar vivident logo on them this
is a company which is the world leader
in prosthetics and machinery for
dentists and once again
their main factory is also in shannon
lichtenstein
[Music]
so by way of a comparison what do you
think is the most important technology
company
in andorra andorra
telecom the public company dedicated to
providing internet
and telephone services to the
inhabitants of wait for it
and dora wow watch out silicon valley
and dora is coming to take you on in all
the listings of andorran companies that
we have found
the vast majority are only sole
proprietorships these are companies
that don't even have a website so you
see my dear visualpolitik friends having
low taxes is not synonymous with having
a competitive economic system and
andorra is the perfect example of that
but what is andorra's problem why
haven't they managed to create
large companies the first reason is the
land in such a small and mountainous
country it is difficult to find land to
build offices look at this news story
from 2020
new luxury development in the center of
escaldes egodani is an impressive
skyscraper
cisa real estate this impressive
has 20 floors and it is the first tall
building to be built in andorra and look
carefully because it's a residential
building that is
it's not an office building so what
problem does andorra have that means
no one wants to set up companies there
we'll tell you that
now from tax haven to corporate hell
imagine and this will be harder for some
of you than it is for others that you
are a successful youtuber and you live
in andorra so far there's no problem the
problem is that you want to grow so
let's suppose that you have your company
created but now you want to go one step
further and turn it into a medium-sized
production company with script writers
editors and animators well
in the first year you're only allowed to
hire two people that's right
two people but wait because this is not
the worst of it andorran labour law is
very protectionist and the premise is
andorran's first
[Music]
that means that by law you'll be obliged
to prioritize adorn candidates over
everyone else hiring foreign talent
means going through bureaucratic hell
just to justify that it is better than
local talent that explains why
apart from the big fortunes andorra is
incapable of attracting talent
[Music]
to continue the comparison liechtenstein
has become an entire hub of medical and
high precision industry if you're an
engineer you can try to find a job there
every day thousands of people who live
in austria and switzerland cross the
border to work in liechtenstein's
industrial estates
meanwhile andorra only attracts ski
instructors and waiters
[Music]
but hold on a moment because that's not
the only issue remember i told you that
andorra has not been able to create
large banks well that's also a problem
since the end of banking secrecy
andorran banks are subject to more
bureaucratic controls than banks
anywhere else
switzerland has several of the largest
banks in the world
liechtenstein has the lgt bank which is
owned by the royal family
seems legit to give you an idea standard
emperors gives this bank an
a plus rating and it is considered to be
one of the most reputable private banks
in the world well andorra has not
managed to take off in the financial
field
either for example its most significant
bank is and bank
according to the rating agency fitch it
has a rating of bbb
triple b and no b is not exactly good no
matter what i may have tried to tell my
mum about my grades
[Music]
but wait we're still not done yet let's
continue with our youtuber example
imagine we're an online creator and we
want to grow our business
okay we can't bring in outside talent
and we're having trouble getting funding
but but
that's okay we could partner with an
e-commerce company and launch our own
branded merchandise it may surprise you
but this is the main source of income
for many youtube channels for example
sally wilt in germany or jeffree star in
the united states have set up
real empires by selling their own
products through their channels
[Music]
the problem is is that andorra is not
part of the european union it's not even
part of the common market while
liechtenstein
serves a bridge between switzerland and
the european union andorra is not a
competitive place to have a store so how
is it possible that andorra attracts
so many e-commerce owners this this is
why
[Music]
drop shipping in andorra a very
profitable business model advantia
exactly
most of the e-commerce sites registered
in andorra use the drop shipping method
and what
is drop shipping and why does it sound
dirty it's not dirty
all it is is instead of having your own
warehouse you use part of another one
[Music]
for example let's say we set up a shoe
store i manage the online store from
andorra when the spanish customer makes
a purchase the warehouse in china sends
the shoes to the customer in other words
i don't even touch the shoes this option
is very good for e-commerce sites that
are just starting but it has
two major drawbacks one very low margins
and two drawn out delivery times indeed
many companies in the industry got
started
using this technique but as soon as they
acquire a volume they end up using their
own warehouses and that's where
andorra's custom situation is
anything but competitive despite its low
taxes
[Music]
in other words if andorra wants to
become the silicon valley of e-commerce
the hollywood of youtube
or the las vegas of online poker it had
better reform and i'm talking
serious reforms
and now i know what some of you are
thinking why do they want to start
companies after all
the country is doing quite well as it is
right and yes you are right
millionaires are to andorra what oil is
to the gulf countries their main source
of income
the problem is is that it is difficult
to control the influx of high
income professionals and if there are no
business ties to retain them it is
likely that many professionals
will end up leaving even more so if we
take into account that andorra has no
cultural integration policies
quite the contrary which incidentally is
another difference with liechtenstein if
they leave it could put a huge hole in
the country's public coffers and
strange as it may seem they know what it
means to have a deficit in andorra
andorra's 2019 budget presents the worst
deficit in the last decade la vanguardia
this news is from 2019
one year after andorra ceased to be
declared a tax haven that is one year
after the wave of youtubers poker
players and small businessmen
started arriving well in that fiscal
year andorra closed with a deficit of
only
2.7 for this year 2021 they estimate
that they will close with a deficit of
but how can you have a deficit problem
in your country when your country is
full of millionaires well because the
nation earns little and spends more than
it should
on what on things like this
[Music]
and dora lawsuit airport could have
several companies operating by next
winter
snow places you heard that right despite
having only 70 000 inhabitants andorra
shares an airport with spain
well at the time of making this video
this airport has no commercial flights
and cost andorrans three hundred
thousand euros a year that's over three
hundred and sixty thousand dollars it
may not seem like a lot of money but
remember that the total revenue for
andorra in 2021 will be 397
million euros
so dear government of andorra if you are
watching this video i think you have
some homework to do if you want more
information you can see the interview we
did with the prince of liechtenstein
hans adam ii
here it's in english but i'm sure it'll
give you some ideas before finishing i
would just like to quickly thank andorra
services vicente rojo and samuel
rodriguez from ecommerce news for
helping us with the research of this
video
meanwhile the question is over to you do
you think andorra is going to make the
necessary reforms to become a youtuber's
hollywood
or are there much better places to live
what do you think is the best place to
live and set up a business leave your
answer in the comments below as always
we really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit
like if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there